we talk about coaches and not getting
opportunities and all this stuff and
eric b enemy
we all know what he does for andy reid
we all know that he handles all the red
zone install and play design down there
in the red zone who's been better in the
reds in the last couple of years than
the chiefs
and yet it looks like we might get to
the end of another hiring cycle with
eric b enemy not getting an opportunity
what is being heard what's being said
regarding this issue as we look at the
coaching
openings in the bigger picture now i
think most people look at it and you
look at the various openings you look at
the people who have been hired you look
at the names of guys that have gotten
interviews like josh mccown and i love
josh mccown but he's got no business
being interviewed
for a head coaching job with the texans
or anyone else at the nfl level
and i think people are just kind of
resigned it's kind of like
okay well all right i guess next year
the the window's gonna open for eric the
enemy i don't know what more he needs to
do
though to convince someone that he's the
right guy
to pair up with a quarterback ideally a
young quarterback
and mold him into a guy who will perform
like patrick mahomes now it may not be
the same skill set
but you get the most out of what the guy
does you design plays that are aimed
to draw out his strengths and conceal
whatever weaknesses he may have
and i i just don't get it and part of me
feels like
and coach you may know this better than
anyone i just feel like these owners
don't like being told what to do and i
just feel like at some level the more
that the rest of us say eric the enemy
needs to be hired
the more they their attitude is we'll do
what we damn well please
well i don't think it's that necessarily
but
everybody is looking for something
everybody has something they're looking
for and i i went through that interview
process
and the the thing that i learned from it
is
you might not be exactly what they're
looking for even though you're a good
candidate
and that happened to me a couple times
i'll give you a for instance
jacksonville jaguars when they were
starting their franchise up wayne weaver
interviewed me and it was great and it
went well
and we came down to the end and he said
i'm really looking for
one person to run everything i'm looking
for that that person who's going to do
it all be the coach and the gm and i
said well that's not me
i'm a coach i don't want to be a gym i
don't that's
that's just not me they hired tom
coughlin and it was a great decision for
them
tom was exactly what wayne weaver was
looking for
the problem then comes is when people go
and say
why didn't you hire tony dungy and
instead of saying well you know he
wasn't exactly what we're looking for i
didn't think he was qualified to do this
this and this
then they said well you know we don't
know and then it becomes well he was not
a good interview
and i heard that after you know a couple
of mine
after that jacksonville well maybe he
doesn't interview well
uh and and that's not it at all
sometimes it just hurts it's hard for
that person to say you know what we
interviewed eric the enemy we liked him
but we liked something
in this other guy's skill set a little
more um
and and i think that's where eric is
right now matter of fact i had a long
conversation with rich mckay
who did a search for atlanta and
interviewed eric the enemy and he said
he heard that
that eric didn't interview well he
called a couple of
reporters and and journalists and said
let me set the record straight eric
banning was phenomenal in the interview
i don't want to hear that but it just
wasn't what we were looking for
we liked arthur smith and we hired him
but don't trash eric the enemy
because we didn't hire it tony does that
help
right there i'm sorry mike where uh rich
mckay will get word out to other people
that this narrative is not true it
wasn't a fit but
and that helps quell that conversation
that keeps building
quote he does an interview well it it
absolutely
does um and those interviews help and i
know people
don't like the rooney rule and they they
really think it's a problem when guys
interview and don't get jobs
but it does help i remember years back
leslie frazier
who's kind of in the cycle now he
interviewed with bill parcells bill
parcells was
in miami making the decisions and he and
parcells had a difference of philosophy
you know we played small guys and fast
guys and built our defense on speed and
parcells was big guys
three four dominant upfront just big
physical
he said i don't know that i could play
your style but he called a few people
and said hey leslie frazier
is really uh he's fantastic
and you you need to talk to him he's got
some it was didn't fit with us
but he's got some good things and i
liked him and that helped leslie down
the road as people said well guys
bill parcells could recommend them um
even though they didn't hire him
maybe he's somebody i need to talk to
and so yes when the rich mckays and the
bill parcells get that out there
to the people in the know it does make a
difference
here's what i'm struggling with first of
all how is eric b enemy not
what one of these teams is looking for
when you consider the pipeline that's
been established of andy reid assistance
in kansas city
doug peterson was what the eagles were
looking for same guy
same demographic same everything
not calling the plays involved in the
play design doing the same things
that eric b enemy is doing and he got a
super bowl win for the eagles
matt nagy ended up being what the bears
were looking for and you look at the
eagles now with nick ciriani how is
siriani who they're looking for but not
the enemy and you look at
the lions with dan camel and biting off
guys kneecaps how is that what the lions
are looking for
and not eric the enemy that's just what
confuses me
how is this got like whatever you think
you want
how is this guy not someone that makes
you say
forget about what we want this is what
we need
well mike um i i look at it that way and
i i kind of chuckled i was going to
write my headline it's not eric b
enemy's fault
it's andy reid's fault andy reid has
lost his touch
because from 2001 everybody he's hired
and put in that position we've said
gosh this is a great guy andy reed knows
how to pick offensive coordinators doug
peterson
uh matt nagy uh all these guys
and and even before that in philadelphia
the same thing brad childress you can go
back
everybody that andy reid has picked and
put in that position has been fantastic
but now he doesn't know what he's doing
he picked a guy that's not very good now
and eric the enemy
a victim of their success and being in
these two cycles going all the way to
the super bowl
you know mike you mentioned that point
there like the dan campbell hire
right that screams to what tony was
saying
of chris spielman was brought in as a
football guy to run the search
are you telling me that dan campbell's
not a chris spielman type guy so the
tony's point
may have been good but we were looking
for a certain type you can kind of see
those connections there not that the
enemy didn't bring that but when i was
listening to the
the kneecap press conference like you
talked about dan campbell
that connected okay this guy and chris
spielman had to connect perfectly
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports